hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walt Urban easy acting today we are
talking about season two of the flash on
the CW it's a show we all really enjoy
and we're gonna talk about season two in
a minute here but I want to remind
everybody that later this week we're
gonna have another bonus episode more of
us I know you guys love it and another
guy you might be familiar with Doug
Walker is gonna be here to review x-men
apocalypse later this week so make sure
you stay tuned for that okay so I wanna
always as always want to thank you guys
for commenting about what you guys want
to see in the show we're gonna cover as
much of what you want to see us cover as
possible keep commenting always comment
and ask what you want to see us cover
and we'll do our best to cover that ok
out now for intros we're gonna go to the
left here first he hasn't been on the
panel while but now she's back my friend
your friend ain't over here he has a
flash you know as well my friend your
friend mr. Brian Porter it's up and to
my right over here the fiery red head of
the show flash season 2 okay
no spoilers first I'm gonna give you
guys a spoiler warning before we go into
some specifics about this season we're
gonna go over all opinions first let's
go with the first overall pains of
season 2 what you think overall I liked
I liked the show flash I actually
preferred season 1 over season 2 I think
the overall arc of the villain I guess
we should say was stronger with season 1
it felt more immediate and intrusive
into his life whereas season 2 it was
more like fisticuffs I don't know more I
would say so i prefer season 1 but I
still like to season 2 overall boy I
liked it a lot too is a really good
season a lot of really strong episode
there was some things I wasn't a huge
fan of but overall I liked it a lot I
think I like this season a little bit
better in season one there's a couple of
things like that I liked better than you
know they were able to get into this
stuff faster you know starting at one so
I like that a lot better I thought it
was a it flowed a little bit better I
liked it okay would you think um I
really enjoyed it
I loved that they brought in certain
elements from the comic some other other
speedsters that I can't go too much into
it will give me good good
but I really like the character
development but they did the season I
felt like they really developed Barry
Allen so I enjoyed that I'm not sure
whether I like season 1 better than
season 2 I liked that season 2 kind of
differentiated from the monster of the
week type formula of season 1 ok my
opinion yeah I think season one's better
by a decent amount at least I think that
having berries you know the whole thing
about his mom dying and everything that
entire situation I think was was that
being the focus like this the core of
season 1 and like going back to that
moment and everything I think that was
just really strong season 2 they got to
branch off and do different things stuff
but there - and everything freakin great
I still really liked it
I just think season 1 was a little bit
stronger overall especially character
wise okay so that is a heart overall
opinions of the show I'm gonna have to
go into spoilers now so if you haven't
seen it yet you can stop here and come
back later but if you have seen the show
keep on watching we're gonna go into
what we like most about the show the
positives from season 2 and we'll start
with Porter what did you think that was
your berry is awesome I like I like him
developing his powers more his speed
better Jay Garrick I really like Jay
Garrick popping up the first episode he
looked great he was an awesome feel for
the character it was really cool to see
Jay Garrick Gorilla Grodd looked awesome
again King shark looked super cool
that's the closest thing we'll ever get
to a live-action street shark saw school
today and overall I really liked the gym
was a badass Tony Todd voicing zoom
super cool super creepy loved it earth 2
looked great just overall I liked pretty
much everything
about it like they had a lot of really
good stuff well is coming back with his
you know kind of Batman evo like it was
really good he whispered but I really
liked him I loved him in Cisco their
relationship together
Wally was cool I really like that you
know just see quick everything
everything about I love pretty much
everything I thought it was really cool
but there are some other stuff that was
not a fan of okay and we'll get into
that I'm doing a negative it's positive
time I really enjoyed Grant Gustin as he
gets those couple episodes where he as
the man tears and I couldn't was crying
so much the model especially one of my
favorite episodes is when he goes back
in time and like holds his dying mother
and it was wonderful and I love that
moment I also really liked Cisco the
season
like you said too I think they developed
him really well I love that he got
powers yes was able to vision and things
like that I also really liked like I
said some of the character developments
that was that was happening there so I
just solid drawing stuff okay which so
many favorite stuff I think my favorite
episode this season was the welcome to
earth 2 episode I think the way that
they handled earth 2 was awesome I
really liked it I actually even liked
the the J like Lions where he's like oh
what's Christmas Christmas that was fun
to like kind of feel out like what's
what is on earth to what's only on earth
one that was kind of fun also I liked
that berry - I guess we can go berry -
looks like Milo from Atlanta
very stumbly yeah so I don't know maybe
I like the little Titanic reference with
Victor Garber talking about an extract
in the back alright so negatives there's
a pretty decent amount so let's go into
negatives right now I undo you have
anything you didn't like as much the
season I actually do I have I have a few
things I can talk about really quick a
season one like the first couple of
episodes did this like Sherlock effects
thing that never came up again why did
we lose that does anyone know go back go
back watch the first couple episodes and
they have like little Sherlock effects
of like Barry looking at the scene and
being like oh it was like a footlong but
never comes back again that was weird
also the security at STAR Labs is
driving me and in including in season
two there's the moment when they're like
we've increased security and then boom
someone walks in they're like at least I
got a good laugh out of that oh good
they beefed up security and they didn't
beep up security it's still terrible
every episode in general like the layout
is kind of like hey Barry we got a beat
this person yeah how do I beat him you
got to run fast how fast hella fast and
then he runs really fast okay that's
literally every episode how fast I gotta
run faster than you've ever run this
little baby I don't super love irises
character
I'm completely agree I want to like
because there's way too much
mansplaining about it feelings in every
episode that everyone's doing for her
like don't tell iris cuz she can't
handle it um that's super annoying too
but I it's not enough to make up for I
don't know the lack of character motive
is motivation sometimes Asian motivation
was the word I was going to coin thank
you
oh he got it yeah I don't love her I
would like to love her more and I don't
really I don't know
I think my best reference I told you
guys before like that episode where
she's talking to Eddie and she's like I
understand that you can't tell me
everything when you get home from work
but if you don't tell me everything when
you get home from work we're done so you
don't understand
I really didn't know how it felt about
like this iris Barry thing going on
because she was so like emotionally
almost stable
I don't I don't like iris iris bugs the
crap out of me like you know in the
season finale a couple of times
Barry's kind of like mobis thinking and
she's just like kind of looks at
everybody like I got I think she goes
out there and talks to him she's very
like sympathetic or whatever and then
it's just like okay we get it you know
you get Barry how about we have
something else talk to him and then
again she comes out they're like and
then she goes talk to Barry yeah one of
the Speed Force cuz he obviously has a
stronger connection with me yeah
but yeah I didn't like her other than
that my only other thing I didn't really
like was Barry's decision in the finale
like that was like oh my god yeah Susie
opens up the time-travelling where's he
going it's like gets back to the house
it's like what as what's happening I was
like well I want on but then I'd like it
one second there was like no your
episode in multiple episodes I'm getting
over his mom's death and they made such
a huge point to it and they went all the
way back on there because his dad died
yeah like that doesn't I don't
understand what the timeline still and
they could still do like a weird future
so much like they took so much care with
the time travel season like it was a big
deal yeah and like he was trying to be
careful occasionally about what he did
like he took they took so much care and
focus so much for the repercussions of
the drunk one of the better parts of him
going to earth to
like the realization that his mom was
alive over there when he was like my mom
called oh my god I love that little spot
that little Easter Egg on the phone it
said Bruce Bruce Clark and they're like
Hal or something like that I don't know
if it's a Diana and - or that little but
yeah I think we all agree that that
ending was it was completely backwards
and I know they're gonna be like oh of
course
because he was emotional and he's gonna
have negative repercussions and stuff
that's the point you're gonna create a
story
well yeah but when you build an entire
season around him getting over a death
and then even the first season was about
that - so you build two full seasons
about him getting over his mom's death
and then in the last episode of the
second season
you completely spit in the face of all
that I thought that was a little stupid
yeah I loved the show like I said but
that was wearing oh yeah so now we've
got some weird flashpoint yeah sorry
about the animation we'll talk about
that later people are gonna hate us oh
hey guys well we're here at CEM Shaw 13
donuts and comics in Crown Point Indiana
and we're gonna talk to some people
about the flash season two once I finish
my donut though
no wonder this room is so safe it's
protected by shield guys look I found
the TARDIS I'm gonna go see if it's
really bigger on the inside I'm here
with Bob so Bob tell me a little bit
about the store what exactly do you guys
do what is this
oh we do donuts and comics it's yeah
they actually work very well together
people come in for one and they end up
walking away with the other do you know
how this came about like why who thought
of doughnuts and comics well our our two
owners Jason Lynette Jason is done
comics and gaming and just he's a real
cultural enthusiast quite some time and
Lynette was a pastry chef at a five-star
hotel in Vegas for a while if you had to
pick your favorite doughnuts that you
have here what would you recommend to
anyone who wants to come oh my I'd have
to say red velvet cake doughnut with
cream cheese we don't make it all the
time but if you come in the store you
honestly see any cake don't they make
here Apple blueberry but with a cream
cheese frosting Oh delightful
now that I know your favorite doughnut
what's your favorite comic would be a
very closely guarded guarded tie between
The Punisher and the post 9/11 run of
Captain America have you heard the news
that Captain America is really a Hydra
agent what that that's absolutely
preposterous I don't believe that Steve
Rogers is an agent of Hydra I don't
believe that all these news reports are
completely blown out of proportion and
that there are no agents of Hydra
anywhere Hydra I think is just a myth
have you watched any of the flash TV
show great show I it won me over when I
could just ask somebody like okay
gorilla grodd's isn't series like all
right it is is iam is he a big monkey is
there a big monkey on the show so I
guess there's like Oh
sold
and it just has a very nice light tone
they embrace the kind of goofiness the
goofy craziness that kind of
characterizes the flash and his rogues
gallery and I really like I'm a big fan
of the show well thanks for chatting
with us today Bob everyone should come
and have a doughnut some coffee and some
comics here at Kemp Shaw 13 in Crown
Point Indiana back to you guys in the
studio
sorry delicious good stuff okay
anyway loins talk about our favorite
characters and performances from this
season I'm gonna start with Henry Allen
/ J Garrick what did you guys think of
Henry's overall story arc and him
revealing to be the actual Jay Garrick
and season Heather I mean I
it wasn't she was a good actor I enjoyed
his performance I did think it was a
little obvious that he was gonna be Jay
Garrick like earth to
but I mean I enjoyed the act um excuse
me doughnuts I did think he was a good
character but I thought it was a little
obvious the reveal mm-hmm yeah Jay
Garrick was awesome
Henry Allen I loved I loved him better
like more so as Henry just because he
had a lot of heart to him I loved every
time he interacted with Barry
like it was especially when he bare he
goes to the cabin after he loses his
powers he's like I'm not a hero anymore
and Henry Allen's like I don't give me
you're still a hero like you're my
son you're amazing you do everything
you're like you're good it doesn't your
powers aren't what to find you it's your
heart and whatever it's just like yeah I
liked him even when he found out that
that he had powers and stuff because he
was like yeah but uh you know the flash
did all the stuff and I'd be really
proud of him if he was my son anyone
else was stood after you guys Cisco man
Cisco goes great his he's funnier than
hell I love all those little pop-culture
quips they're hysterical his t-shirts
are always awesome and I liked his story
arc with you know harnessing his powers
more how he dealt with reverb especially
like this old samurai situation any time
Cisco's on the screen there's a gold
my love's disco is probably my favorite
it's the only good thing about Caitlin
is the interactions right I loved the
way he interacted with Caitlin after
going to earth to specifically because
he dealt with killer frost and then kept
seeing her as killer frost after that
and then when she got to be able to like
play a track on him by saying like
Caitlin I always hated that man and he's
like when we think of zoom slash Jay
Garrick slash 100
I'd like someone to go through and count
how many times someone says run Barry
because I swear it's like at least 10
times per episode I would like to see
which character gets it the most I want
one day on the future season for Barry
to turn round like no I'm the flash
it's kind of what I do just keep running
real fast okay so um are you excited for
season three they kind of stop the
flashpoint paradox like you said before
you guys excited to see where we can go
with this for sure here's what I want in
season three musical episode og hear me
out no no I actually that's not why but
most of the actors on the show can sing
we've already seen it a few times also
go online and I don't remember which one
of the actors uploaded it but they all
sing a song on YouTube - fantastic yeah
so go check that out also go do neither
I think I have any superhero if anyone
can do in a flash so make it happen
please I I want whatever happens in you
know flashpoint paradox instead how cool
would it be if we saw a little allusion
to Terry McGinnis Batman Beyond kind of
like a dark shadow with some pointy
wings and like a red symbol or whatever
in the eyes like what and he just kind
of like zooms by or whatever it's like
any kind of illusion to BAM beyond
anything at all I'm four so I would lose
weight collector with amnesia it would
be amazing I'm excited for season three
I'm as frustrated as I am with the
ending I'm excited to see where they're
gonna take it especially like you've
already mentioned with black flash and
like some of the other speedsters that
they hinted at I'd like to see Wally
West get some speedster powers because
Wally West is my favorite flash
yeah I spent most of season cheer just
being like okay so when do they get
their powers and then they so we're all
excited for season 3 I think season 2
overall was still a really good show I
still love the flash because right
behind daredevil for me but season - I
think dropped off a little bit just for
me yeah for regular Network super girls
come in - 2 CW so that might be
interesting to see how they cross over
the CW shows now yeah so that's gonna be
interesting
ok pick of the week here I mean my hands
are all sticky I got bacon grease
there's a lot of talk about rebirth
right now with DC rebirth well I wanted
to suggest a flash rebirth by Geoff
Johns so this brought Barry Allen back
from the abyss he was in the Speed Force
for years after Christ and in traverse
and this is the the title that brought
him back into the DC Universe so you get
to see him interact with Wally and Bart
and a bunch of different different
characters that he hasn't seen in a long
time and just see how sing how he comes
back and integrated back into the DC
Universe and how he goes forward with
everything and how this basically leads
up to flashpoint and everything you
could see the little seeds planted in
here for that and this is a really good
read so go ahead and check it out it's a
lot of fun and if you like the flash if
you like confusing time-travel stuff
you'll love this so go ahead and check
that out okay so that's our thoughts on
season 2 of the flash later this week
once again we will be reviewing x-men
apocalypse with Doug Walker so make sure
you come back - that'll be a bonus
episode and next week we will also be
talking about Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles out of the shadows what Doug
wants to join us for that one - we all
know he's a big team and tea fan so
he'll be on the show for that as well we
got double Walker action in next two
episodes of possible comics so social
media oh you guys where can you find you
you know where to find me it's right
here
Instagram Facebook Twitter Bogut
facebook.com/ / awesome porter alright
alright you can always find me on
twitter at awesome underscore Walter I
wanted I forgot to mention this earlier
we have a new Facebook page guys you
need to go check out because there is a
ton of bonus extra stuff that we put up
on there all the time for to reviewed
issue 1 of DC universe rebirth wanna
check that out we'll have exclusive
pictures exclusive mini reviews and
everything and we're also going to be
putting up a mini review of arrow season
4 that Porter is gonna do that I'll go
up exclusively on the Facebook page so
make sure you check that out awesome
comics on facebook at facebook.com/
stars awesome comic show so you need to
go check that out if you are enjoying
this conversation and as always don't
forget to Like comment and hit that
subscribe button to you do with
your friends if you liked it so much
yeah and if you want to see more about
just comics in general go watch our all
comics episode yep a couple weeks ago we
do a summer comics previews to go ahead
and check that out if you want to know
more about our specific thoughts
I haven't specific comic books ok
everybody so for everyone here until
lair this week when we will be like once
again we will we will we we will be
reviewing we will be really we will be
reviewing x-men apocalypse with Doug
Walker I am multiple asiak these folks
are awesome and we will see you on the
next page
you